yeah
so you've always been really creating on
youtube for quite a while really yeah
creating in general yeah i'm a
compulsive creator right
so
is there like a next step of what you
want to achieve after you're done with
this documentary
uh interesting that you say that because
i did actually uh come in contact with
two
two producers involved with um creating
content for for example streaming
services or even hollywood actually
concerning
christian obviously oh wow but yeah so
so they've seen my work and and um
of course they see they see dollar signs
after
after this recent debacle
so
but yeah so we're interested in maybe
creating something i'm i'm not sure yet
if it's possible but yeah either um
american network or netflix amazon maybe
streaming i don't know about uh
christian christian oh like like a
feature well honestly it could be we
you know true crime is all the rage
right now
this is now a true crime story honestly
unfortunately this is like
this is a netflix level story
like it's like an avengers level threat
no this is
making a making a murderer looks like a
joke yeah this is like making uh making
a christian yeah but it's like honestly
this black mirror thought it was dark
until this story we could have a five
season netflix show about this yeah
honestly justice it's
oh my god yeah that would be very cool
yeah
i'm just curious how how much longer do
you think it would take to uh catch up
to catch up to the story because you're
at what 2017
2017 yes
november 2017. uh part 60 we'll we'll go
into 2018 finally
so maybe another 10 another 10 episodes
yeah maybe this is like the anime
adaptation that catching up to the manga
right
it has to be
i don't even know how i would feel being
in your shoes i don't know
you know i'm sure one hand i really want
this to conclude on the other hand i'm
like oh god what am i going to do after
this
exactly yeah uh yeah i i guess you know
other than the movies or any other
future plans that you have or creating
stuff or music do you want to be done
with this yeah that's a good question
yeah kind of
but
but if the opportunity arises like for
example if i if i if i can get something
done with netflix like i can get my name
up there this could be like a stepping
stone a stepping stone right yeah yeah
exactly i mean i feel like now
you must be the go-to guy for
information about this as they say i am
the christian guy
you just you've you've been the only
person who has been able to present it
in a way that
it doesn't make you feel like you're in
some weird internet forum kind of like
finding out about a guy who you
shouldn't be looking at yeah
you know whereas i feel that the videos
very much presented
like we said in an objective way that
makes you not feel
too bad for consuming it whereas i feel
like if you're reading it online you're
like it's just weird yeah like i
shouldn't be here kind of things yeah
yeah i don't know this was wrong i like
i'm fueling this right
um yeah well i mean i
wish you the best of luck i i really
want to see what else you can do
i'd be interested in what other
documentaries you could pull off yeah
god knows that you've proven your your
uh your dedication to your subject i
think no one can question that when you
go deep on a subject
you know if someone's making a
documentary about anything i'll like get
gino right yeah that man has gone in
hard
you know
massive props to you man i have
absolutely massive respect for the sheer
amount of work you've put into this and
i
you know i i don't think i've put
one-tenth the amount of effort into
something in my life so i really
congrats i guess
thanks i'm gonna go and watch the rest i
promise you should i'm sure episode 10
right now i've only got what like 50
episodes to catch up on it's all right i
can do it if i catch up on one piece i
can catch up on this yeah i was about to
say i caught up on one piece like i'm
gonna catch up to the rest of you you
should watch it it is very compelling
it's very well done gino's done an
amazing job and of course links in the
description to all of gino's channels
yes check out his music as well and uh
yeah he's our third channel where he
does documentaries and stories about
yokai right damn don't you want to plug
yourself anymore anything else you do
yeah i'm good
well there you go then yeah man oh gino
man thank you so much for coming on this
has really been a pleasure
and uh
what was i going to say this is for the
most different episode of trash taste
we've ever done it's been an
enlightening episode yeah eye-opening to
say the least this is probably the least
tangents we've ever talked in an episode
yeah right this it's almost a themed
episode in a sense
but yeah i i've just it's definitely
been an educational episode
i don't know if i wanted to be educated
now i am apparently
um but it has also been fascinating yeah
super fascinating
yeah i don't know what else to say it's
it's probably been like the episode
where i've found it the hardest to talk
yeah right
sometimes i'm just like how do i even
react to this stuff yeah it's other than
making a just dumbfounded face it's just
going to be like me making youtuber
reaction faces throughout like two hours
of this
we should get all the thumbnails just
like the thumbnail just looks like yeah
just use just use me and gaunt for
thumbnail faces because we made so many
this episode just listening to these
stories
it's absolutely insane is there anything
you'd like to say to the viewers before
we uh end this any final thoughts final
thoughts um
christian's story is very very
complicated
and
it can
it can uh serve as a lesson
for for many things in life servers
listen what not to do on the internet um
how to um how to behave in in-person
relations as well um
it can
well basically uh
see it and think for yourself because
that's what i really encourage with my
series is that you make your own
decisions i'm not going to tell you what
you think